cifras devastadoras del comité
internacional de la cruz roja tras una
década de la guerra civil casi la mitad
de los jóvenes sirios han perdido un ser
querido dejando a esta población
particularmente vulnerable según un
informe publicado por la organización
cuando se investiga cuántos padres
murieron o resultaron heridos se llega
al resultado de que uno de cada seis
sirios tuvo a uno de sus padres muerto o
herido
a fundir el conflicto ha dejado miles de
jóvenes desprotegidos sin apoyo familiar
añadiendo a su condición escuelas
bombardeadas como esta
además de la escases de alimentos y una
economía paralizada de los sirios entre
18 y 25 años casi la mitad ha perdido
sus ingresos y seis de cada diez ha
informado en asistencia escolar según el
sondeo de la cruz roja casi el 80% han
reportado tener dificultades para pagar
sus necesidades básicas y con gran parte
del país en ruinas millones de personas
han sido desplazadas en anaheim han
pasado 10 años desde que vimos por
primera vez y alrededor de 3 desde que
vivimos en este camión dormimos aquí
comemos aquí debemos acción solíamos
tener una casa pero la permanentes no
tenemos nada más que este camión está
vivo aquí con mis siete hermanos y
hermanas habiendo perdido su infancia y
su adolescencia en la guerra muchos
jóvenes se enfrentan el reto de
reconstruir su país siria mientras éste
enfrenta la peor crisis económica desde
que inició el conflicto en el año 2011